on attendait pas léo ferré à paris les
communes tarn être entré sur scène deux
ans hewitt et vous que faisiez vous je
suis chez moi à la campagne où ça depuis
deux ans on n'avait pas chanté
vous avez enregistré principalement des
poèmes de verlaine et rimbaud mais je
crois le disque est sorti votre décembre
et depuis ma vous allez recomposée donc
pour ce tour de chant maintenant oui je
vais faire un disque cette semaine et
puis je chante ici à bobino des chansons
de ce disque mais on ne nous attendait
pas effectivement comment se fait-il que
vous soyez à bobino précisément bien
vous avez traîné devait faire ce
spectacle et il est malade on m'a
téléphoné
j'étais prêt enfin j'ai des chansons je
suis venu parce que les chats sont sans
peut-être moins moins acide quelquefois
moins dure au jeu par ce ver on prétend
que je suis assis dessus dire moi je
pense pas
il fait les chansons que je désire faire
enfin j'ai pas tout façon c'est pas à
moi à dire si c'est de dire aussi c'est
acide et la vie là-bas donc dans le lot
commence pastel d'habitude eh bien je
travaille je me promène avec pépé vous
savez ma petite pp qui a passé fille
chaîne basée et qui est notre grande
affaire et puis je suis heureux quoi
parce que je suis libre puis je suis
presque tout le temps dehors
vous venez souvent paris ou très
rarement ça ne vous intéresse pas
tellement j'aime beaucoup paris m'enfin
maintenant je le réinvente de loin celle
à l'absence favorise l'amour quoi qu'on
dise
que des manières au fond des ligaments
ça se prend ça ce qui de sas doublé
l'eau liquide
après la nuit le jour ça choisi des
toilettes des toilettes on guette un
coin de paradis
quand ça part en voyage ça traîne à
chaque page une photo de la vie
ça s'envoie des outrages et ça crie et
sa rage et sa ce titre bon ami
quelquefois ça serait auto warta wallet
et je te parle du pays
sa part dans les étoiles aux vins rien
sa cavale dans des foutus endroit quand
ça tombe ça rigole en deux elle s'assoit
cole et sincère plusieurs fois
la ce a choisi d ivresse des ivresses me
laisse un goût de revenez-y ça y revient
et s'attarde opt-in potable accroché
ça s'envoie des promesses des promesses
qu'ils cessent dès que tout le vent tout
juste si ça dure huit à seize mesures
la chanson des amants